The joe rogan experience,
but out of that lack of confidence that you get or that lack of sense of like
not everything's threatening,
not every,
it's even like a roast.
I come not even good at roasts because I take things personally and if I'm going
to insult somebody,
I mean it,
there's no,
you know what,
I'm cutting to the bone.
I'm not looking for the laugh.
I've gotten better at that.
I can,
I can take the hit a little better and I enjoy it.
But,
uh,
but it's really hard if you're a competitive person,
Andrew Insecurity,
you have no sense of healthy competition.
No one's going to want hanging around with you and everyone's going to think
you're a Douche bag.
And what you said is really important.
It's sort of threatens your self definition when you lose someone taking
something away,
right?
It your pride.
You're like,
you know your manlihood,
you're,
you know,
like how other people are going to see you.
It's fucking like,
there was one time,
this is rock and roll oriented,
but uh,
it's kind of a funny story in,
in this that there's a real difference between judging yourself against other
people and,
and just judging yourself against your own work.
It's a,
it's a hard shift to make cause like a lot of my career was built on like how
that fucking guy get that,
why is that guy popular?
Why can't you get me to get,
why can't I be on that show?
What the fuck?
As opposed to not realizing at that time.
Like I got all that stuff.
A lot of my breaks early on,
we're out of spite and looking back on it,
I wasn't ready for it and I,
and I botched it just because like I had no,
you know,
I was all about the competition,
but there was this one time where,
you know,
if I was at a music camp and,
uh,
it was just basically my parents sent me to this camp and they let you smoke,
it was great.
I was like 14 and we could smoke cigarettes and play guitar all day.
Wow.
Yeah.
And then the final night,
like,
you know,
there was a big performance where the people in the camp put together bands and
stuff and uh,
and you perform for the whole camp in this big band shell.
So of course I ended up with these fucking stoners and shit heads,
you know,
and we're just like the guy I had played bass,
he was okay.
Long haired dude,
they're all troubled guys.
And a while we wanted to do is play some chuck berry songs.
You know,
I figured how hard could Johnny be good be,
you know,
how hard we should be able to pull that off,
right?
And we're all,
you know,
1415 years old and then there's this other crew of kids that were complete
fucking music nerds that like new fucking how to read music.
And that could play better than any of us in.
So here's what happens.
So we go on and all the dudes I'm with get fucked up before we go on stage,
which is doing Johnny be good man.
It's,
it should be easy.
It's three courts.
My drummer's too fucked up to play drums.
The guy on piano is not playing in the right key and it was a disaster.
I started singing out of key.
It was the most shameful and embarrassing fucking thing.
I might as well just shit my pants on stage and then we get off and those other
guys get up there and in my memory they played the entire side of a genesis
album.
That's my memory of it,
that they got up there and they did some amazing thing and I felt fucking
invisible.
I felt ashamed and to,
you know,
literally till maybe two years ago,
I couldn't fucking,
I was afraid to sing in front of people for half of my life
because of that.
And if I just,
you know,
put more thought into,
making the song better and working with these dudes and just like learning how
to do that shit,
I wouldn't have fucking,
it's a weird story and I don't know if it really applies,
but I do know the feeling afterwards of embarrassment and shame and I felt that
those guys had won and I fucking hated him for it.
This in the Bible,
man,
that story as iron people sharpen people.
Yeah.
So what it is,
man,
you need to feel that.
You need to feel lost in order to realize what you did wrong,
but you can't live in it.
Yeah.
You can't live in it,
but you,
it motivates you to move forward and it motivates you.
But that terrible feeling shouldn't be ignored.
It should be figured out.
It's like you got to figure out what,
what is,
what is causing this?
But you can lock into that feeling for many years.
Like all the crazy like,
you know,
the cargo cults co what's the cargo cult?
Come on.
I don't know.
My favorite thing.
Cargo.
Yeah,
the cargo look up cargo called does.
I explained what it is.
Okay.
So Papua New Guinea was a staging point for the American army during World War
II and they cut these impossible,
uh,
runways into the jungle.
Right.
And,
but the people who were living there were like Bronze Age people.
And so they saw these planes come out and then,
and then,
you know,
they would give them like spam and whatever.
Like stuff,
you know,
parachutes.
And so then they left at the end of the war and they started a whole religion on
the plane.
So they built these planes and they come in and they mimic the landing and they
mimic the people coming out.
And they still have the American uniforms and the,
the,
the tribesmen with like a bone through his nose.
And if you like one dread,
we'll come out with like Chi,
you know,
captain fucking Joe Adams,
and then they'll,
they'll bring like the law,
the empty cans,
cans of spam and shit.
And they have these like planes made out of flowers that they pretend to launch
and stuff.
And you're like,
this is the craziest fucking,
just really watching religion did they made,
they made the religion because of the planes,
you know,
the beef 52 coming with supplies and the whole religion is like the plane is the
vessel of God and the Captain Joe Abrams who comes out is that he's God.
And then this right Giorgio sucralose,
which spike his hair up and come in here and say,
is it possible that the reason why these things exist that we learned them from
aliens?
Yeah,
I mean it makes sense if,
if you live to stone age life and a plane landed and gave you some spam,
100%,
it would become folk lore.
And it's gotta be so strange if I think they are they illiterate culture?
So no,
I mean yeah,
the cargo called they do,
they do the whole religious thing through the reenacting that when the planes
first landed.
But actually there's a thing now they are kind of littered now because these
people in New Guinea who are fighting Exxon,
there's a lot of oil there.
Exxon is trying to turn to um,
exploit the oil and these uh,
tear they,
well,
whatever,
everyone's going to get oil though.
Cause if there's fucking oils and was going to get it,
but they have this trial,
but they have this tribe now that's dressing as,
um,
you know,
the gods,
the car,
the cargo co,
and they're attacking Exxon dressed as American servicemen from 1942.
I think the whole theme of this is from American 1942 today.
But like,
it's,
it's cool because they make big,
huge white helmets.
And then,
uh,
if you Google God,
that's Google,
uh,
Papua New Guinea versus Exxon.
And you'll see the crazy outfits.
John's very,
he doesn't know as Bell Papau New Guinea.
He barely knows how spells is new.
It's pretty fucking interesting that there's a whole,
it's a huge country.
Patenting is massive.
And there's a whole like how big Texas sized?
Oh,
much,
much bigger than Texas.
Really?
And you have a big,
big country where like,
uh,
like huge pockets of it worship cargo from 1944.
Oh my God,
I changed up 42 to 44.
Is there,
um,
is there a big city like where you can go and get Wifi in a Starbucks?
Yeah.
Um,
does that too.
There's that too.
It's just like a cheesecake factory there.
Popular might be,
you can go get a Starbucks.
Can I get a Starbucks?
If I went to New Guinea,
you can probably get some sort of pizza hut product.
Wow.
Okay.
Oh Shit.
Itunes or recording to server the fuck outta here.
Server.